well Germany's president is urging
citizens to put their faith in science
as set instead of conspiracy theories if
they want to avoid getting kovat 19
Frank Felder Steinmeier expressed
concern at the declining acceptance of
government imposed restrictions in the
country
it has seen a surge of protests against
restrictions in recent days Germany
hadn't witnessed scenes like this in
weeks thousands gathered at an official
demonstration in downtown Stuttgart last
weekend calling for greater freedoms
during the corona pandemic despite a
recent loosening of restrictions
I think the way they're dealing with
this pandemic is a bit over the top
driving the whole country into the
ground putting 83 million healthy people
in lockdown
and winding the economy down that's
never happened before we're here to show
that we're not Outsiders people here
aren't from the Green Party or eco
freaks or hippies or from the
alternative for Germany or whatever
we're normal people from the middle of
society we act responsibly and we always
have to we're responsible citizens the
demonstration is loud but peaceful and
most hear respect the social distancing
rule but protests like this one have
also attracted people who are using the
crisis to promote their own cause among
them conspiracy theorists and extremists
according to you des gana I wasn't in
Stuttgart I was in Berlin and it's clear
to see that the number of people trying
to hijack the demonstrations especially
right-wing extremists is far higher in
Berlin
then in Stuttgart I'm swimming I've been
there fellas
at an unauthorized demonstration in
central Berlin things got out of hand
anti-vaxxers conspiracy theorists and
right-wing hooligans were among the
crowd a prominent participant is attila
hilde man hildren became known for his
vegan cooking videos on social media
these days he's demonstrating against
coronavirus restrictions and spreading
conspiracy theories he also claims that
sedatives have been added to Berlin's
drinking water his social media channel
garnered 30,000 subscribers in just two
weeks
you can laugh about it and wonder what
kind of person craves such attention in
times like these but of course it's also
totally dangerous because he's calling
exactly these kind of people to arms
saying we have to defend ourselves we're
facing a superior enemy and so anything
goes the German government has expressed
concern that violent right-wing
extremists could sway opinion especially
among those doubting the validity of the
current restrictions further large
demonstrations have been announced for
this weekend and for a closer look at
conspiracy theories on the rise I'm
joined now by Mikael bucho professor of
American Studies from the University of
Tuebingen he's an expert in conspiracy
theories thank you so much for joining
us here on the program and I'd like to
begin by asking you the self-proclaimed
resistance 2020 group has really become
one of the main players here in Germany
and spreading theories that the corona
virus pandemic is overblown that the
media is causing mass panic why do you
think these views are gaining traction
right now well I think they are gaining
traction because conspiracy theories are
answering to a feeling of insecurity we
know that people are drawn to conspiracy
theories if they are bad at dealing with
ambivalence or insecurity and what time
could be more insecure than the current
one where nobody knows how our life will
be in a couple of weeks and in these
times conspiracy theories offer
seemingly easy answers because they
identify the people allegedly
responsible and the alleged
and behind all of that and they ensure
people that they don't need to worry
about themselves and the health of their
loved ones because all of these
conspiracy theories claim that the virus
either does not exist or is completely
harmless okay but where do you think it
comes from I mean because it's really
gained quite a lot of popularity
especially we've seen it you know
playing out in German society where is
the skepticism coming from from from
about the official information well I
think this is a longer story and we've
had this for years and most of the
people taking to the streets and this is
also where I disagree with the experts
who said that there were less fewer
conspiracy theories in Stuttgart than in
Berlin most of the people who are taking
to the streets in the moment in
Stuttgart for example our conspiracy
theorist these are people who were
already part of the man Mohamed for
peace in 2014 and also of anti-refugee
protests in 2015 for example so they
have been spreading conspiracy theories
online for years many of them
anti-vaxxers - so it's just new that
they are now taking to the street again
but this is not a new formation but this
has been there for a couple of years and
concurrently it's not just conspiracy
theories because the German greens have
also pointed out that some corona
skeptics are spreading anti-semitic
ideas how big is the danger of
anti-semitism also growing out of these
protests I would not overestimate that
at the moment I wouldn't worry too much
I mean what were observing with Korona
conspiracy theories is that they just
latch on on to conspiracy theories that
people have believed on anyway already
and it seems to me that the amount of
anti-semitism that we're seeing at the
moment is relatively small compared to
other conspiracy theories that dominated
the community for a while so compare
this for example to the great
replacement conspiracy theory which
tends to blame George Soros the American
billionaire for masterminding the plot
now we have Bill Gates as the evil
mastermind and as horrible as that is at
least it's not an enticing
arguments so I think just as the
conspiracy theorists are in panic about
the measures of the state that they
consider inappropriate and horrible
there are politicians who are in panic
about conspiracy theorists and I don't
think that one shouldn't be too much
worried about that it's still a very
very small movement that is getting a
lot of public attention at the moment
mchao buta professor of American Studies
and an expert in conspiracy theories
thank you thank you so much for having
me